الصينيه طبعا الطالب المبتعد حامد الهنائي
موجود هناك خلينا نعرف شو اسم المنطقه اول
شيء صبحك الله بالخير صباح الخير عندكم
صبحكم الله بالنور لا حنا بعدكم نحنا
باربع ساعات باربع ساعات
طيب اسم المدينه شي ان شي ان شفت شلون هذه
انا قبل كم سنه رحت 2018 رحت بكين ما عرفت
اتعامل لانه اللغه صعبه وحتى نطقها
ودامينز عادل يعني اذا كان هذا اسمي ما
ادري انا قاعد اقولها صح ولا غلط
قريب قريب شفت شلون تعلمتها سهله
بدايه تعلمتها
بدايتي وانا في المدرسه سوي نظام دوله
الامارات بدو مشروع اللغه الصينيه من كان
عمري يمكن ست سنوات سبع سنوات لين يومك
هذا
فاليوم الامارات او دول عربيه او الدول
الخليجيه قاعد تستثمر في الطلاب عشان يكون
عندهم خبره زين كافيه عشان يتعاملون
الاشخاص الصينيين طب يا حامد انت بتقول من
من وهو عمرك سبع سنين بلش تتعلم اللغه
الصينيه بنحكي عن
تحديدا مش اوكي اوكي معنى ذلك بانه هلا
انت صرت بلبل زي ما بقولوا
نوعا ما ولكن في مستويات في اللغه
امتحانات جدا ولكن ما اشوف في مع تدريب
واحد يتعلم بشكل فعال يستخدم مثلا مصادر
ثانيه سواء انا مثلا اول فترتك انت
ادرس في الامارات
صار موضوع كورونا وصار هذا تاجلت امور اني
انتقل للجامعه بشكل اسرع لكن الواحد لازم
غير انه يدرس مثلا الجامعه لازم هو
يستخدم مصادر نفس الكتب يشوف افلام
يشوف اصدقاء سنين يتعرف عليهم اليوم بشكل
اسهل واحد يتعرف على ناس هل نعم
حامد هل من السهوله ان انت تتعامل مع
الصينيين بلغتهم انه يعني قد تخطئي
يعلمونك
النطق الصحيح للكلمه هناك ايضا يعني
الجامعات الصينيه في عندها اقسام للغه
العربيه ولكن حتى من يتحدث اللغه العربيه
اجت صعوبه في التعامل معاه
بالنسبه للصين صحيح انا انا بالنسبه لي
اول شيء نبدا في اللغه الصينيه هي من
اللغات الصعبه والمعقده بشكل عام ليش
هي تتميز بنظام كهرباء مختلف عن جميع
اللغات الاخرى سواء سواء كانت مثلا كوريا
ولا هذا الدول المقربه لها هي نظامها
مختلف تماما بالكتابه نتحدث
لانها رموز كليات نعم نعم وايضا في الصوت
مختلف تماما يعني يستخدم الواحد يوم يقول
كلمه يستخدم اصوات للتعبير عن المعاني
يعني بشكل مختلفه بعطيكم مثال يوم واحد
اذا يقول كلمه
هذه كلمه بما معناها رقم اربعه اوكي لكن
اذا قالها بشكل
هذه كلمه بعيد الشر والله يطول في عمركم
معناها الموت
فمرات اذا الواحد يقولها بشكل سريع مثلا
ما يلقطها
خاصه اذا انا مثلا اكلم واحد صيني وما
يلقطها بشكل صحيح يفهم المعنى بشكل ثاني
مختلف
ممارسه بشكل كبير اكيد صعب جدا لانه يعني
مش بس حتى لو تعلمت الاحرف وهي مش احرف هي
رموز هل الكتابه ايضا صعبه مش بس النطق
يعني انت تتحدث عن اصوات مختلفه لنفس
الكلمه تعطي معنى مختلف بالنسبه
للكتابه هذه رموز كلها يعني مختلفه عن اي
لغه ثانيه احنا متعودين عليها
ايوه هذا الرموز اصلا قبل تعود تعود قبل
هذه الرسوم كان في ثلاث مراحل كانت مرحله
كانت رسم قبل تطورت كانت رسم الى كتابه
الحين صارت الى كتابه لكن اليوم اذا نشوف
كلمات مثلا
كثيره موجوده في الصيني واحد يعرف معانيها
يشوف المعنى موجود في الكلمه
اشياء تعبر عن شيء مثلا كلمه الماي او
كلمه النار فيها شيء يعني يعني فيها حاطين
نفس جناحة وهذا فتبين انها مثلا نار اذا
الواحد يعود الى معناها قبل او كيف كانت
تتم كتابتها تكون رسمه تمام طيب حامد كيف
تقول صباح الخير صباح العربيه ولا حتى
صباح الخير بالصيني
ايوه صحصح الحين صح هي ولا صح انا
منو صح
لازم اراضيكم لكن صحي صحي حمد
العلمي راويه العالمي طيب شكرا جزيلا الله
يعينك يا حامد على على يعني وعلى تعلم
اللغه الصينيه وان شاء الله ترجع وتكون
دائما من المبدعين ونستفيد دائما من خبرات
ان شاء الله شكرا
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات